so there's Sainsbury's 139 a liter for
petrol 143 for diesel wonder if that'll
be the cheapest we can find
in Watford
watch every town in Britain you have to
work quite hard to find the cheapest
tank of fuel and look at that Tempe more
expensive that's because supermarkets
aren't working as hard to keep prices
down according to the competition
Watchdog which says profit margins have
grown
Asda in particular historically has been
the cheapest of the supermarket back in
2022 they took a decision to increase
their internal margin targets actually
trouble their margin targets we saw a
similar move by Morrisons to double
their targets now in a market where
competition is working well you'd expect
other retailers of the supermarkets
other fuel retailers to respond
competitively to seek to win market
share we haven't seen that happen at all
more than half of the price of a liter
of petrol is made up of fuel Duty and
vat with another quarter or so set by
the oil price after refining costs and
exchange rates the retail spread
including costs and profit accounts for
11 percent
but the CMA found that while the pump
price here in red has fallen from its
peak of almost two pounds the Gap with
the wholesale price in Black has grown
A1 taxis run 150 vehicles in and around
Watford offering fixed prices yeah
nowhere is going to be up around 10-15
minutes yeah Adil says the lack of
competition for fuel is hitting drivers
and customers the supermarkets you know
there's not been much difference in
price between them and your you know
your shelves and your BPS you know with
that client base being the working class
how do we reflect that in the prices uh
without upsetting them and losing our
customers the supermarkets say they are
committed to competition but government
will now force them to share information
so it turns out Asda is the cheapest
just from Sainsbury's but it's taken
quite a lot of driving to work that out
the recommendation is it is made easier
for drivers by retailers providing
real-time live price information that
could be used on a phone it could be on
your Sat Nav make it easier for you to
find the best deal that will increase
competition locally hopefully bring down
prices
motoring groups say the move is overdue
we see today very much as a landmark for
drivers we hope that it's going to lead
to fairer pricing on the fork or going
forwards uh the presence of a Fuel
Finder to allow people to find the
cheapest fuel them near them is a good
move
wider profit margins at Asda and
Morrisons have come after both were
subject to debt-fueled takeovers with
financing costs to meet on top of
inflation drivers may have to wait for a
better deal Paul Kelso Sky News in
Watford